now there was a guy that was there named
Ron Wilson Ron Wilson
ran in if you look in the newspaper it
says it's like a aund million Ponzi
scheme but really it was $57 million so
he had lost 57 million so it says 100
you know they you know they always
exaggerate because 57 is not enough Ron
ended up getting 19 and a half years Ron
was an old con man mhm early 60s 62 61 I
don't know and uh Ron I and I liked
Ron
um so we're walking around the compound
and he's like so what are you going to
do I me like eight or nine more years to
go and I was like you know I'm going to
keep writing and when I get out of here
maybe I'll have a huge body of work and
maybe I'll be able to sell it or maybe
I'll be able to option some more stuff
and if I could get together with rolling
stone or get with some of these
magazines I could start writing for them
and I could option those maybe I could
walk out of here with or something so
right right right so Ron was who'd only
been locked up like a year or so he was
cooperating with the Secret Service in
his case against some of his
codefendants so he's he's already been
debriefed and he's cooperating he's
actually thinking he might get brought
back to have to testify at a
trial we're talking and we're walking
and he keeps saying you know even if I
even if they they charge those guys and
even if this happens they're not going
to reduce my sentence they're not going
to cut my
sentence you know first of all well
probably because you stole a bunch of
money from Pension funds and churches
that didn't help your case but I don't
say that uh so I I say oh they have to
Bro they'll have to they they you know
if you cooperate they're going to have
to and if they don't we'll have Frank F
2255 and he's like uh ah that crazy
mother um so he says uh okay he's like
yeah yeah you don't understand you don't
understand so this goes on for months
and I and I'm like what is the problem
and he says you know they think I hid
Ponzi scheme
money you know and he'd actually dug up
like five or six million dollars in
Ponzi scheme proceeds that he dug he he
he buried in these oh literally
literally buried in aluminum ammunition
canisters mhm super interesting guy so
he actually went and dug them up and
gave them to him and I'm like well you
gave them all the money it's you didn't
hide anything relax it's not a big deal
they're not going to find anything so
don't worry about it and so he mentions
it a couple weeks later couple weeks
later and then one day I go bro why do
you keep bringing this
up like what are you concerned about
there it's not going to happen and he
said can I trust you and I went probably
not and he
goes I did hide some money I was like
okay I said you you you bury in a can
somewhere and he's like no I I um gave
my wife like 150,000 in cash I said okay
well she's not going to say anything
she's using no you don't understand
since then she found out I was having an
affair and she we're going to get a
divorce and she hates me and I think
she'll turn that money in just to make
sure that I don't get a
reduction because if you lie to the FBI
they're not going to it doesn't matter
what you've done for them they won't
give you anything and so he's BL I mean
I'm sorry Secret Service or anybody he
is clearly lied to the secret service at
this point if she goes and says this is
what he gave me MH so he's like I was
like oh wow and he's like and I gave my
my brother's holding maybe 30,000 for
me
and at that moment I was like
wow like this poor guy no that's not
what I thought at all what I thought was
is that enough to get me a sentence
reduction you son of a
[__] and I went and I sat there and you
know what I thought I thought I I I I
thought no I thought that's not enough
that's not enough it's nothing that's
not even
$200,000 like and they didn't want to
give me a reduction my prosecutor was
pissed that I got seven years off she
wanted me to get 30 months she's not
going to give me anything it's up to her
she's not going to do it so I go I lay
down I go to bed like a month later I'm
on the phone with my lawyer cuz I had
written remember I wrote A Man U my I
had a manuscript for my book and I
wanted to put some of the stuff that was
said at my in my sentencing in the
book so I was trying to get my lawyer to
mail me my transcripts and she hadn't
done it so I called her and I said
listen you said you were going to she's
like oh God man I'm so sorry I'm so busy
I'll do it I'll do it and then she went
this is Esther she was so what else is
going on in there and I this she never
wanted to talk to me like she didn't you
know when they were paying her she
didn't want to talk to me and and I was
like what do you mean nothing I just
need my my transcription she's like
nothing's happening there's nothing you
want to talk about and I was
like and I like you know
what you know what there's something
weird happened there listen to this and
I told her about Ron Wilson and she goes
hold on and she looks up the computer
she say oh wow this is a bad guy this is
a bad
guy and he told you then you know where
it is I absolutely she and I can tell
you exactly and she goes okay okay okay
she goes uh let me look into this I go
okay
so a week later a a CO comes to me and
goes hey Cox and I go what's up he goes
listen at the next move because you know
they have controlled moves all the doors
are locked and they open them up for 10
minutes so you can run to the chow hall
or you can run to the you can't run
though there no running on the compound
but you can walk fast yes to the wreck
yard uh or the library whatever he says
at the next move go to
sis you know so I go to Sis on the next
move but I was used to going there by
the way because I I was constantly
ordering Freedom of Information acts and
they would so I'd order your your an
inmate and I'd order I'm writing a story
for you and I'd order it and they'd send
it to me and then they would catch it
and they'd be like why are you getting
Lex's information so they'd call me down
there I go no I ordered it for him and
I'm writing a story and I'd already been
in Rolling Stone every day like what's
the story and I tell him the story they
that's a pretty good story here and so I
go down there but this is different this
the guy answers the door and his guy
they call him Bulldog using real [__]
uh he was a lieutenant of sis and he's
like uh come in get in here Cox sit down
and he dials the phone he goes here you
got to talk to this guy I'm like what I
pick up the phone I'm like hello and the
guy goes hey this is Agent Griffin with
the Secret Service I understand you know
where Ron Wilson is has uh hidden Ponzi
scheme money I whoaa whoa whoa I want
something in writing I want you know so
I start doing that and they go okay I
get us his email address and we start
emailing each other back and forth and
he ends up S getting a letter
from the US attorney in South Carolina
that says they will consider it
substantial assistance if they if they
make arrests or recover a substantial
amount of money that's the best I'm
going to get is consider so I start
talking to this guy and he starts asking
me questions about Ron Wilson like hey
ask him this ask him this so I'm like
bro I gotta kind of work that into a
conversation that's an odd thing to ask
so this goes on for six months
so I'm asking questions and I'm typing
up little reports and I'm I'm a I'm a
I'm a prison snitch now so I'm not just
like cooperate I'm now I'm a prison so
I've I've moved down I've moved down
actually from being just a cooperating
witness or because you're in prison is
that what makes you a prison pris Stitch
you can't even really say um no you
could say prison rat you can say prison
rat I think prison snitch I think that's
probably the closer to the term that
most guys would you what's the
difference between a snitch and a rat
and prison I'm not sure I it rolls off
the tongue better prison rat doesn't
sound as good as prison snitch I don't
know m i don't spend a lot of time
thinking about this so what happens is
um I'm asking Wilson questions
periodically and at some point they
contact me and they say
listen Wilson's about to get some bad
news and I go
okay um and and they go he's you know
like I want to tell you what it is let
us know what happens it's like two days
go by and one day Wilson comes up to me
one day and says [__] [__] and I'm like
oh [__] I'm like hey what's up you know
and he's like oh my you're not going to
believe this I got indicted I was like
what what
happened no yeah my wife they questioned
my wife and my brother and my brother my
wife walked in first she said I don't
have nothing I don't know what you're
talking about the next day the brother
walks in and gives them
$150,000 in cash and so the next day the
wife comes back and gives them
$250,000 in cash and a bunch of uh
silver like gold bullion and silver you
know because this he was a his his Ponzi
scheme was based off of
Silver you know he was going to invest
in silver for you so
half a million dollars they turn over
half aill I'm like half a million
dollars I thought she was like a h
100,000 or something and he was he was
like I know I didn't know I could trust
you I'm like
Ron what are you doing I thought we were
so he um so I'll tell you something just
for the icing on the cake by the way the
icing on the cake let let me explain one
more thing y there's so if you're going
to if somebody cooperates with the
federal government let's say I get
arrested and they go you want to help
yourself and you go yeah okay um look uh
Jimmy is a he lives next to me and he's
running a meth house you know meth lab
whatever and they go and they raid Jimmy
and he gets arrested you're going to get
something off for that not a lot but
you're going to get
something
now and they could just say we were
going to bust him anyway we were already
on to him right now the next level would
be you wear a
wire so I wore a wire and I I was in
danger now keep in mind I'm asking this
guy questions inside federal prison I'm
in danger so whatever that's like the
next level you're active you're taking
an active participate participation in
the um investigation and the third level
would be you actually get on the
stand and you cooperate and you you
testify there's no better cooperation
than that
so when Wilson says to
me
they're going to move me back to South
Carolina they've indicted me they
charged me what do you think I should do
and I go I think you should go to
trial because I know they'll have to
call me as a witness yeah just to let
you know because I don't I don't want
you to I don't want to walk out of here
and have you feeling feeling like hey
there's some there's some good to this
guy no so I'm ready I'm I'm ready to cut
Wilson like a fish so yeah but you are
putting yourself in danger if you get
understand right I'm already in danger
if if people there heard what I was
doing I probably would have been in
doesn't that increase the chance of them
hearing or no it does but it also
increases my ability to get more off my
sentence that's true so what happens is
couple days later he's on What's called
the pack out right they're going to move
him maybe a week later so they come and
get him they move him he gets back there
to South Carolina and he pleads guilty
he he they sentence him he gets six
months added on so he's now from 19 and
a half to 20
years uh and and by the way when Co hit
he was released so he only ended up
doing like six years on a 20-year
sentence because he was older he's by
that point he's 66 67 years old you know
he's an old anybody older than 55 was
endangered especially in the prison so
they had a a CO thing where they were
releasing these guys and sending them
home on ankle monitors like he's an old
man he's not he he's not going to hurt
he's not he's not a danger so they sent
him home so he ended up doing so he
didn't even serve the six months he
didn't even serve the original sentence
whatever not that I care so I'm just
saying makes you feel like poor Ron it's
okay so his wife got like a hundred year
a 100 she got like a hundred hours of
community service or something or 60
hours and I think his brother got six
months papers they they got charged with
um obstruction of justice you know and
they didn't neither one of them you know
it's like six months
probation and community service nothing
so when we I turn around I'm waiting for
my reduction waiting waiting after about
90 days after this guy gets sentenced
maybe six months I send a letter hey
what's going on to the prosecuting to my
prosecutor their the prosecutor of both
districts no response then I go to Frank
I explain to Frank and Frank has known
what's going on the whole time and Frank
goes uh okay I'm going to file 2255 so
we file
2255 government comes back and they
first thing they say is your honor we
don't know about any cooperation we've
never heard about any cooperation so of
course then we submit the letter that we
have the judge comes back and the judge
ends up saying it's a little complicated
but he ends up saying look I don't have
jurisdiction to hear this
because you're you may be time
barred but I'm going to let the the
appeals court hear it now typically you
have to you have to get what's called a
like a right of cert a certification to
appeal you have to make sure that you
actually have a case he says I'm waving
the
CT and I'm waving the $500 fee to file
with them he said and I'm he's he
basically expedites it for me which is a
subtle way of telling the prosecutor I
think he's got something and I'm sending
it up there and he and the way he writes
his motion it's basically saying I don't
have the jurisdiction to hear to do
anything but they do they need to do it
and I'm Paving the way you don't have to
pay any money and you don't need that
sir so the prosecution immediately comes
back they file a a a on level
reduction and we immediately Frank files
something saying hey stop we don't want
the reduction we don't want the one
level we want to come back to court
please don't don't rule on it so the
judge says okay I'm freezing everything
I'm I'm putting a stay on everything I'm
going to give this guy a
lawyer to try and figure out what you're
going to do they fly down uh lawyer
Leanne
Weber so she comes and and she comes and
sees me and uh she says listen I I I see
that you want to go back and fight this
and this but honestly I don't think
you're going to get anything more than
one level uh I talked to the prosecution
they said they'll give you well she said
I can work on trying to get you two
levels but you don't have much of a
prayer you're going to get crushed and I
said well then then why are you here if
they can crush me so easy why don't they
do it why would they pay you like they
pay them like 12 Grand or something just
to fly down and all your expenses to to
negotiate for me why not crush
me and she's like I I don't know I said
well Frank said four levels and she's
like who's Frank I go Frank's the guy
that wrote All This and she's like oh is
is he an attorney and I go is he in here
I'm like yeah he's in here she's like
why is he in here and I tell her he was
taking over the world yeah and she
says that's the strangest thing I've
ever heard in my entire life and I said
I understand but Frank said and she's
like you're listening to an incompetent
you know I'm like
absolutely and she and Frank said for
Lev we want four levels she he said for
me to tell you we want four levels she
say okay she leaves she goes to the US
attorney we argue two levels they come
back say two levels no we go back and
forth we start filing motions saying we
want to go back we want a hearing we
want to bring back all the FBI agents
the Secret Service agents and she's like
what do you want to turn this into a
circus exactly what do I want to do I
going to turn it into the biggest circus
because I've already got one
level they come back one day she says
listen three levels is the best you're
going to
get she said so uh I guess you'll be
moved back here we'll go to the hearing
I said no no no I'll take three levels
and she go what are you talking she said
you said four levels you said Frank
wouldn't take let you take anything less
than four I said no Frank said to tell
you four I was happy with three I wanted
you to argue for four I'm good with
three I'm out of here in like a year
yeah so and I don't want to be moved
back I don't want have to get on that
bus you know what it's like to be moved
it's horrible so I said I just want the
three levels so then we argued about the
wording for about 2 3 months and then
they file it and then I get 5 years
knocked off my sentence because three
levels at this at the level I was at now
isn't seven years every level you get a
little less time so I get five years off
so now I've got 12 years knocked off my
sentence at this point
I maybe have a year and a half to go M
and you know that's
doable so I was super super
happy um and I'm G to I'm going to tell
you
something uh and I'm sorry bro um but
every time I think about it and I I just
feel like I have to say
it
like I'm Frank I'm
insane but I can like I didn't have a
[__] prayer without that guy and as
crazy as he is and much of a pain in the
ass as he
was um like I could never repay him bro
like like I'm not I shouldn't be here
I'm supposed to be in prison right now
my outdate was 30 was
2030 without that guy where is he now he
got himself out he didn't do all that
time he got himself out I don't even
know how he did it they even threw him
back in prison again for six months and
he got himself out again uh he's insane
he's incredible he's insane but he's
incredible is he really that insane he's
in
Orlando is he I mean he seems like he
seems like a good lawyer and a good man
he he's he's he's great he's great I
mean there's no doubt in my mind I would
be in prison right now if it wasn't for
him and he's done this for others walk
people right out 10 years off five years
off nine years off 10 years I mean it's
I didn't pay and I didn't pay for one
thing I didn't pay for my stamps he paid
for
everything sounds like the other lawyers
don't really believe as possible and he
does it's interesting well I think he's
he was willing to he's willing to Badger
them into doing you know what they
should have done to begin with I
actually wrote a book about it which he
loved about him about him and his story
his it's so over the toop what happened
with him um I mean lit I tried to to
take over the Congo I mean there's a a
documentary about it there's it's called
nine days in the Congo it's an insane
story I'm I'm that's one of those
stories it's just like how is this not a
movie it's not a movie yet no I don't
I've pitched it several times and uh
it'd be it would be great but so I wrote
a synopsis and I turned that into a book
what's the name of the book oh it's
Insanity it's Insanity yeah but about it
like a year and a half later like I
ended up getting out of prison and I
went to the halfway house